trouvez vous normal qu'un homme qui a
des enfants qui économise tous les mois
pour payer les études de ses enfants
aient besoin de l'accord de son chef
pour engager une note de frais à 10
euros comment expliquer qu'une femme
très engagée dans sa vie personnelle
l'association des parents d'élèves les
clubs sportifs face le strict minimum
quand elles viennent dans son entreprise
qu'est ce qui a provoqué ce
désengagement et qui prive l'entreprise
de cette énergie
trouvez vous normal qu en général dans
les organisations se sont vont souvent
les improductifs qui disent aux
productif comment il faut travailler des
spas le monde à l'envers
en fait pendant quinze ans je ne m'étais
même pas posé la question
aujourd'hui je me suis éveillé notre
aventure commence en 95 nous lançons en
france une innovation de service un
métier sexy très sexy le dépannage de
flexible hydraulique sur site
notre rêve à réseau d'intervention un
véritable samu du flexible qui va
arriver dans l'eure et dépanner dans
l'eure nous allons vivre une croyance
incroyable un tourbillon d'énergie et
déjà déjà à l'époque on était on était
une entreprise un peu décalé alors je
vais vous l'avouer oui nous avons fait
les calendriers avant les rugbymans la
différence c'est que nous on est une
équipe mixte alors quand on a trouvé ça
sympa on l'a fait hier après nos clients
puis après et puis après nos clientes et
là on a vu qu'on avait un beau métier
douze ans après la création de la boîte
on a passé la barre des 300 équipiers
l'image qu'on a de l'entreprise à cette
époque c'est un un porte avions on est
puissant
cent mille interventions 50% de parts de
marché on va huit fois plus grand que le
premier confrères et déjà de nouvelles
entités naisse le groupe innovant
appareils et puis le porte-avions c'est
une bonne image aussi parce que parce
que vous soyez beaucoup de peau sur un
porte-avions et nous on a commencé à
strates et l'entreprise lui tout va bien
on a vraiment l'impression de vivre une
aventure une aventure merveilleuse
on est même un peu fier vous l'avez
compris il y en a surtout été fier mais
ça va pas durer longtemps
2009la crise de 2009 arrive on prend la
porte en pleine gueule 34 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires s'évapore c'est le
drame pendant huit mois on tente de
réinventer l'entreprise mais rien n'y
fait et on est obligé d'y arriver
pour sauver l'entreprise on est obligé
de virer des gens qu'on n'a pas envie de
virer c'est terrible on se réveille avec
une gueule de bois qui va pas passer
personnellement c'est un drame 15 ans de
travail acharné 15 ans de sacrifices
il ne reste plus rien capté de fumée
petit à petit au fond de moi va naître
une question qui va devenir une
véritable obsession
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour que jamais ça
recommence alors je cherche je ne sais
pas ce que je cherche
et ça va durer des mois et puis un jour
un jour je reçois une invitation à une
conférence qui va changer ma vie elle
était intitulé l'entreprise du 21e
siècle existe nous l'avons rencontré je
vais rencontrer ce jour là jean françois
zobrist l'ancien patron emblématique de
cette famille de cette fonderie pardon
de cette fonderie picarde favy quelques
mois plus tard je vais rencontrer isag
est le coauteur du livre liberté et
compagnie ces deux hommes vont ouvrir
les yeux sur cette philosophie qu'on
appelle l'entreprise libéré et grâce à
eux
grâce à eux je veux comprendre que
pendant plusieurs années pendant quinze
ans exactement j'ai fait deux erreurs
fondamentales
la première c'est que pendant 15 ans
j'ai géré mon entreprise pour les 3%
alors qu'est ce que c'est les 3 % dans
toutes les organisations il ya toujours
à peu près 3% couillon 3 % de gens qui
trichent qui respectent pas la règle et
moi pour tenter les contraintes et bien
je mettais des règles des notes de
service et j'avais pas compris qu'en
faisant ça en fait c'est toute
l'entreprise que je punissait et et bien
jean les limites est complètement la
capacité d'action et de réaction
mais la deuxième erreur est encore pire
parce que je garde le pouvoir en manger
rond eh bien je vais privé l'entreprise
de sa plus belle richesse la puissance
de son intelligence collective imaginer
300 cerveau qui ensemble ont décidé de
servir la même vision de boîte et c'est
moi le patron qui en privaient
l'entreprise faut être con quand même
avec mon équipe nous décidons nous
engager sur un principe très simple nous
allons agir sans rien dire privilégier
l'action à la communication et nous
commençons par trois chantiers premier
chantier un chantier où nous allons
reconstruire notre vision et nos valeurs
arméno post it on va faire le tour de
france allait voir toutes nos équipes et
nous allons reconstruire notre aventure
le rêve commun de chacun de nous et de
nos équipiers deuxième de le en même
temps pardon nous allons construire nos
valeurs ce premier chantier nous a
permis de redéfinir le terrain de jeu
est ensemble de choisir les règles du
jeu le deuxième chantier on s'attaque
aux petits cailloux les tickets ou dans
les chaussures vous savez les irritants
du quotidien un ordinateur et une
casserole
une machine qui se dérègle tout le temps
alors on va s'en occuper on va nettoyer
le plus possible et ça ça va donner de
respiration en entreprise on pouvait
reparti à roue pour démarrer la partie
troisième chantier des signes de pouvoir
exit les titres sur les cartes de visite
les costumes au placard aujourd'hui j'ai
plus de bureaux échos d'hier sont
ouverts à tous et à tous et non
seulement nous ne fuyons plus les
réseaux sociaux mais nous nous y sommes
réapproprier parce que 100%
d'informations stratégiques
il est partagé
mais ça suffira pas il nous faudra
encore 12 longs mois toute l'année 2011
pour nous préparer à les travailler sur
nous et nous allons entamer les
démarches individuelles avec des coachs
pour nous aider à explorer nos croyances
et à travailler notre la surprise
un grand club derrière mon ami jean
louis qui nous a tellement aidés à ce
moment là à la fin de cette année à la
fin 2011 on se sent prêt prêt à faire ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon des
entreprises libérer le saut en parachute
vous savez pas facile de remonter dans
l'avion quand on a sauté eh bien c'est
ce geste symbolique ce geste
irréversible qui va montrer à toutes vos
équipes que plus jamais demain ce sera
comme hier chez nous ça se passe ce 7
janvier 2012 ou rassemble toutes les
équipes dans une grande messe et là on
va faire renaître l'entreprise et leur
transmettre le pouvoir
comment ça se passe exit le porte-avions
et bienvenue à notre armada de speed
boat vous savez les speed boat les
petits bateaux efficace rapide dynamique
tout ça forme et dans une armada qui
vont ensemble servir la vision alors ce
sont les équipiers qui vont choisir le
nombre de speed boat nous région ensuite
ensemble ils vont le définir le rôle du
capitaine
et oui il faut bien un capitaine sur un
bateau et ensuite par un processus
d'élection sans candidat ils vont
choisir eux-mêmes leurs leaders
le capitaine nous venions de faire
renaître l'entreprise ensuite nous leur
donnons le pouvoir
ils s'inscrivent dans un des vingt
groupes de travail que nous avions
ensemble construit qui rassemblait tous
les sujets de l'entreprise maintenant
choisissez votre animateur est décidé et
nous mettrons en place tout ce que vous
décidez la transformation était lancée
cinq mois après
je m'en vais je vais partir avec ma
femme stéphanie avec de trois enfants et
nous allons partir faire un tour du
monde pendant une année
d'abord parce que c'était un rêve
d'enfant a besoin de retrouver les miens
mais aussi un besoin de me désintoxiquer
de cette entreprise où j'étais devenu
addict mais oui mais parce que pendant
ce voyage il s'est passé quelque chose
que je redoutais quelques jours avant de
partir une des équipes m'apprend qu'elle
souhaitait engager la refonte intégrale
de la rémunération variable du groupe
lutz vous imaginez dans quel état je
suis à ce moment là ils vont faire un
travail incroyable pendant neuf mois ils
vont tous travaillé toute la boîte pour
reconstruire ce nouveau système
et quant à mars 2013 on met en place ce
système simple de partage de la valeur
créée ça s'est passé comme dans les
livres
le chiffre d'affaires a pris 15% sans
rien faire d'autre mais surtout la marge
a été multiplié par quatre faisant de
2013 la meilleure année depuis la
création de l'entreprise
alors quand vous revenez de voyage les
goolrick l'entreprise va beaucoup mieux
quand vous étiez là
comment dire ça fait très mal à la
fierté mais quel bonheur de voir les
équipes chaque jour s'épanouir un peu
plus comment ça marche aujourd'hui mais
comme dans toutes les entreprises
libérer la clé de voûte du système
la vision et les valeurs au coeur du
système et à la confiance qui se traduit
de quatre manières chez nous la première
chose c'est que l'information n'est plus
un enjeu de pouvoir
la seconde c'est le principe du
volontariat vous voulez participer à un
groupe de travail qui va choisir le
nouveau véhicule d'intervention ou
nouvel opérateur de téléphonie mobile
il faut juste en avoir envie troisième
principe l'autocontrôle basculer d'une
logique de contrôle à une logique
d'autocontrôle et puis le dernier
probablement pas le plus simple
réussir à développer dans l'entreprise
une culture d l'erreur non seulement
l'accepter mais l'encourager plus
concrètement encore comment ça se passe
qui recrutent
ce sont toujours les équipes qui
accueille qui vont recruter il faut
qu'ils soient tous d'accord à
l'unanimité à chaque fois des capitaines
nous l'avons dit les capitaines sont
cooptés par leurs équipiers et ils ont
un mandat trois ans les anciens managers
eux et bien sont reconnus pour leur
expertise et ils la partagent à tous
pour faire grandir tout le monde les
décisions de processus simple
l'assemblée des capitaines is réunissent
toutes les 6 à 8 semaines et ensemble
ils vont trancher toutes les grandes
décisions de l'entreprise
et puis les groupes de travail qu'on ait
évoqué tout à l'heure même la gestion
des augmentations de salaires et des
investissements est confiée au collectif
chez nous alors forcément dans un
contexte comme ça le blues des patrons
changes jeudi des patrons parce que nous
sommes trois courts animateurs jérôme
claudio et moi même notre boulot ça
change complètement le premier job c'est
remettre la vision au coeur de l'action
tous les jours jean françois di remettre
l'église au milieu du village
privilégiez la question plutôt que la
réponse deuxième job créer cet
environnement nourricier comme un
jardinier pour aider ces plantes à
grandir et puis la troisième chose c'est
un rôle de gardien parce que la liberté
fragile
et c'est notre job de préserver cet
écrin c'est notre job d'être le garant
de cette culture d'entreprise je propose
qu'on s'arrête maintenant et je vous
propose un regard en arrière un regard
sur ces cinq ans de transformations ya
quatre idées qui rentrent en moi qui
remonte et je voudrais partager avec
vous la première c'est un dicton
africain que parfois je n'aime pas
beaucoup ils vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin
la seconde idée si vous voulez engager
une transformation dans votre
organisation
si je veux changer mon entreprise
qu'est-ce que d'abord je suis prêt à
changer en moi le troisième idée une
phrase que je vais en prince est
emprunté à richard teerlink l'ancien
patron de harley davidson
ce n'est pas que les gens n'aiment pas
changé c'est que les gens n'aiment pas
qu'on les change
et quand on comprend ça on peut changer
bouger de montagne et puis la dernière
la dernière tant qu'on n'y a pas été
confrontée on peut difficilement la
comprendre
que d'efforts que d'efforts il faut
faire pour ne pas agir
tu ne te rends pas compte tu ne te port
rend pas compte de ce que ce changement
dans l'entreprise a comme changement
dans ma famille j'assiste à ce moment là
une conversation entre une équipe fière
et puis un visiteur j'arrive à dire à
mes gamins aujourd'hui c'est pas grave
si tu te plantes
j'ai confiance en toi et je sais que tu
trouvera la solution et je sais qu'un
jour tu réussiras pour moi c'est une
bombe
je comprends ce jour-là que l'enjeu
c'est plus innovants mais si les 300
familles je comprends que par extension
et vous savez qu'il ya des milliers
d'entreprises des centaines
d'entreprises qui se sont engagées et
pas des moindres est que par extension
ce sont des centaines de milliers de
familles qui vont être concernés
serions nous en train d'assister aux
prémices d'un vrai d'un grand changement
et si cette refondation sociétal que
nous sommes nombreux appelée de nos
voeux était en train de naître au coeur
de nos organisations
et si les entreprises libéré celle qu'on
fait le choix de la confiance et la
liberté pouvait changer leur monde
j'en ai acquis la certitude et quelle
chance incroyable d'en être le témoin le
témoin de cette transformation qui
mettra en son coeur l'homme et la
planète
peut-être certains d'entre vous
connaissent cette légende amérindienne
celle du colibri à jour dit la légende
un terrible feu embrase la forêt les
animaux sont pétrifiés ne sachant que
faire
seul un colibri fait des allers-retours
et jette à chaque fois quelques gouttes
d'eau sur le feu alors le tattoo énervé
lui dit arrête plus riches ne sert à
rien c'est n'importe quoi ce que tu fais
et colibri lui dit mais t'as pas compris
tu as tout ce qui est important pour moi
c'est quand je fais ça je fais ma part
et moi quand je partage cette aventure
cette histoire de transformation
l'histoire de cette équipe que j'admire
temps et bien quelque part je fais ma
part
le monde bouge le monde change et c'est
maintenant que ça se passe moi j'ai
décidé je m'engage et j'ai une envie une
énorme envie celle de vous donner envie
d'avoir envie envie d'expérimenter la
confiance il a liberté au sein d'
orgueil organisation alors si certains
d'entre vous ont envie aujourd'hui et
maintenant ici et maintenant on vit de
nous rejoindre de nous rejoindre et de
tester dans vos organisations la liberté
la confiance et bien je vous propose
maintenant je vous propose maintenant de
vous lever
je vous invite à partager votre
engagement
je vous invite à rayonner de votre
enthousiasme je vous invite vous aussi à
changer le monde